cosmetics have been breaking gamers bank
accounts for years and years now but sometimes
you've got to look good to play good some
skin connoisseurs just want to collect them
all while others want to represent
their favorite players and teams
some of them change the look of your weapons and
some change the look of your entire character
but one thing that everyone can
agree on is that certain skins
are just sexy some skins look so good that you
just can't resist buying them some skins are so
rare that if you don't buy them you'll never see
them again so here are the top 10 sexiest skins
kicking off our list is one of
counter-strike's rarest skins
the orb dragon lore oh my god no way i got
a dragon lore i got a dragon lore please no
get away no way in july 2014 the cobblestone
collection was added to cs go and featured the
first weapon with the covert rarity tag but this
case also featured consumer and industrial tier
skins which meant that the chances of actually
opening a case and getting a dragon law is roughly
one in 2.5 million so you can understand why some
people get pretty excited when they unbox one
i told you dude
the dragon law is a thing of beauty but you don't
have to take our word for it plenty of pros use
dragon laws of their own and famously kenny s
made his name as csgo's most legendary author
using a dragon lore named the magic stick can he
he's inside of this he's trying to play clever
with this awp and he's got one no no way kenny you
gotta stop the price of a factory new orc dragon
law can vary given that these things don't sell
every day but they can go for thousands of dollars
but hey you could always buy a cobblestone case
for a couple of hundred bucks and test your luck
instead of your wallet taking our number nine spot
are the only skins to become a pop sensation kda
the kda skins in league of legends
were released in november 2018
following the release of the group's music
video for their hit song pop stars and
apparently they sold well because riot will
not stop releasing more and more kda content
the kda skins are some of the most elaborate and
beloved skins in league at this point even if
sometimes riot screws up the marketing a little
holly got a job kylie go to work always on fire
don't get burnt i try not to get burned but it's
not always easy when you're spitting hot flames
at number eight on our list is a balanced skin
that might actually make you better at the game
why do i get headshots why do i aim better why do
i just feel better playing with the prime vandal
the prime skin set has been invalorant since june
and as soon as it came out people started thinking
it might somehow be pay to win is the prime vandal
better than any other gun i don't really know this
is kind of the meme that's been running around is
that the prime vandal is just the best vandal now
the prime vandal probably doesn't actually make
you better a head shot but there's no denying that
it looks sick maybe that little visual confidence
boost is what's convincing people it's secretly op
maybe i was actually thinking about it i might
actually go to the prime because i actually really
like the look of the yellow prime and just the
animations and the prime basically feels like a
aimbot and the number seven spot is the only skin
on this list that's actually literally sexy street
fighter 5's hot ryu street fighter 5 launched
with ryu's shirtless bearded battle costume but
fans quickly nicknamed it something a little more
appropriate hot ryu and that name burst a meme
here is a close-up of the box art we got ryu
and chinley here on the front and they're
hot edition a little bit more skin than usual fans
all over the world were falling in love with this
shirtless bearded man and soon enough capcom
got in on the action they officially changed
the skin's name to hot ryu and started making
action figures in his honor here you can see
two pixel pals that are still in the box luigi
and hot ryu which it's hilarious to me that he's
called hot ryu it's because he has no shirt and a
beard which apparently makes you very attractive
driving into the number six spot now we have
rocket league's gold rush we did it ladies
and gentlemen we have the alpha boost i'm so
hyped man i'm so freaked out often referred to
as alpha boost this item was given to players who
participated in the game's alpha test it's rocket
league's most expensive item by a long shot coming
in at roughly 5 000 us dollars at the moment
and the price has only continued to rise since the
game's launch in 2015. i am finally a proud owner
of the alpha boost baby we got it flying in at
number five we have overwatch's pink mercy because
nothing is sexier than donating to charity helping
those in need is its own reward when pink mercy
was introduced in may 2018 alongside a charity
campaign all proceeds from the skin went to the
breast cancer research foundation that means that
if you own this skin you are the ultimate support
player pink musty means you're a messy mane and
if you don't have the skin i'm afraid you simply
aren't a real mercy mane overwatch players
helped raise over 12.7 million us dollars
for the charity in just two weeks and once the
skin was no longer on sale fans begged blizzard
to bring it back but for now we can only hope that
maybe one day pink mercy will reappear in the shop
sliding into number four is the flashpoint race
skin from apex legends it quickly became one of
the most sought after skins in the apex community
when it hit the shop in june 2019 and it's not
hard to see why it's one of the most radical
costume changes for wraith shaving her head
and putting her in an uncharacteristic bright
blue outfit but stop us if you've heard this
one before respawn stop selling the skin so just
like pink mercy fans begged the apex devs to put
it back up for sale literally the only thing
i want in this game is flashpoint i will give
away all my skits for flashbacks what do i have to
do josh to make you guys re-put this in the game
unlike basically any other limited edition skin
though respawn actually listened in march they
brought back the skin in a season 8 update so
now anyone can get their hands on this beauty
coming in at the number 3 spot is the legendary
black eye skin line from rainbow six siege
all purple purple purple oh
i got black eyes for buck c8
the black eye skins in rainbow six siege are
the rarest in the game with less than a two
percent chance of them dropping when
you open an alpha pack in the game oh
epic black guys oh [ __ ] let's go now black
eye skins haven't been released yet for
shields but about a year ago some players found
in-game files for them and with ubisoft teasing
them in some of their preview videos hopefully
we will see some black ice shields pretty soon
taking our runner-up spot now we have valance ruin
dagger introduced as part of the episode 1 act 3
battle pass this melee weapon was awarded
to players who completed all 50 tiers of the
pass and then finally the knife the dagger
the ruin dagger this is me 100 my new knife
i'm only going to use this knife for now on i need
a i need to only play games on this account so i
can get this knife unlocked this was riot's first
rendition of counter-strike's beloved karambit but
compared to the other knight in the game the ruin
dagger featured new uniquely satisfying animations
last but not least the nice looking ruin
dagger that looks like those cs go skins
that you see certainly i have flex on the
noobs while using the ruben dagger right
the karambit unfortunately if you weren't able to
complete the battle pass from that act you didn't
get the skin and chances are you likely won't be
getting another chance to earn this knife ever
again we couldn't just leave you with only one
knife on this list so we decided that the number
one spot had to go to cs go's butterfly knife this
video is about the butterfly knife or as i like to
call it the best knife in the game these were some
of the first knives ever introduced to the game
and they've been asked here ever since oh god i
like it yes stewie's got that and the follow-up
released back in 2012 valve has just never managed
to create something that can top it doesn't matter
if you're using a doppler or a fade there is
simply no cs go skin sexier than a butterfly knife
and they've been part of some iconic cs go moments
he has a glock of course and he's able to hit and
j somehow out of bullets on the knife skadoodle
what's he doing a double knife can he get the
third he gets the right click and rush finds gaps
smoked out bomb down everyone chasing down gets a
tremor the knife comes in simple of course stabs
him straight in the chest in a game like counter
strike there isn't much else you look at more than
a knife and if you don't think that this thing is
sexy then i don't know what is just look at these
animations alright guys what did you think of
that did i miss out any good ones that should have
made it onto the list don't forget to subscribe to
the channel if you haven't done so already thanks
for watching and i'll see you all in the next one
oh you got it
what is he doing
oh i think i just broke my
nose because i face planted my